we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
this is an interesting observation about
some of these recent interviews that
donald trump has been doing take a
listen
hey david i was just listening to the
fox and friends
interviewers your coverage of that um
i realized that trump at this point has
gotten
so bad at inter so bad at even the
propaganda interviews
yes they literally have to give him the
answer before he answers their question
if you replay the brian kill me he asks
the question
gives him the answer and then waits for
trump to just say yes
basically yeah that's what we're going
to do and he still
finds a way to mess it all up yes i have
noticed this
uh if friendly interviewers will pr it's
sort of like
priming a five-year-old to give you the
answer that that you know how like
when you talk to little kids just by how
you talk to them you can basically get
them to go along with with a lot of
different things and you say
hey uh little donny um
do you like it is the apple or the
cherry bigger
right which one looks bigger does that
apple look bigger
yes yes the apple looks bigger you're
priming answers
and friendly interviewers will do this
to trump and they'll do it when they ask
them these
seemingly simple questions like what is
your agenda
or something about the virus they give
him the answers
and trump could say you're absolutely
right that's exactly right and i'm glad
that we're all on the same page
trump still gets the answers wrong when
some somebody gives them the answers
and uh astute uh
that's an astute observation from our
caller on the bonus show today
los angeles is saying they will shut off
water and electricity
to homes hosting large parties and
gatherings in the context of coronavirus
can they do it what will happen we will
discuss
also new york city as we are starting to
see a resurgence in cases in a lot of
different states
new york city is setting up quarantine
checkpoints for travelers who are coming
in
from coronavirus hotspots massachusetts
is thinking about similar
strategies what is the fall going to
look like and lastly
on top of everything we've gotten an
updated 2020 hurricane forecast
and it looks very bad and we already saw
in florida what happens when you combine
a relatively small hurricane tropical
storm
with a coronavirus outbreak we are going
to discuss what happens
when it is a major hurricane combined
with the coronavirus hotspot all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
i'll see you then or tomorrow